So far, we have used what is
known as internal validation
to test our model.
This means that we took the
data from one set of patients
and split them into a training
set and a testing set.
While this confirms
that our model is
good at making predictions
for patients in the Framingham
Heart Study population,
it's unclear
if the model generalizes
to other populations.
The Framingham
cohort of patients
were white, middle class adults.
To be sure that
the model extends
to other types of
patients, we need
to test on other populations.
This is known as
external validation.
There have been many studies
to test the Framingham model
from the influential 1998
paper on diverse courts.
This table shows a
sample of studies
that tested the
model on populations
with different races.
The researchers for each
study collected the same risk
factors used in
the original study,
predicted CHD using the
Framingham Heart Study model,
and then analyzed how
accurate the model
was for that population.
For some populations, the
Framingham model was accurate.
For the ARIC study that tested
the model with black men,
this figure shows a bar graph of
how the Framingham predictions
compare with the actual results.
The gray bars are
the predictions.
And the black bars are
the actual outcomes.
The patients are sorted on
the x-axis by predicted risk
and on the y-axis by the
percentage of patients
in each group who
actually developed CHD.
For the most part, the
predictions are accurate.
There's one group for which the
model under-predicted the risk
and one group for which the
model over-predicted the risk.
But for other populations,
the Framingham model
was not as accurate.
For the HHS study with
Japanese-American men,
the Framingham
model systematically
over-predicts a risk of CHD.
The model can be recalibrated
for this population
by scaling down the predictions.
This changes the
predicted risk but not
the order of the predictions.
The high risk patients still
have higher predictions
than the lower risk patients.
This allows the model to have
more accurate risk estimates
for populations not included in
the original group of patients.
For models that will be used
on different populations
than the one used
to create the model,
external validation is critical.